bitcoin currently is super bullish we
hear so much good news about bitcoin all
the time coming out now
um even though it crashed right
fundamentally bitcoin has never been
more positive than right now
which is because of institutions trying
to see that their inflation is very high
you know it's like two three percent of
the dollar a month
and they want to find some way to stable
out their balance sheet
so they put one or two percent to
bitcoin so i can see that the bitcoin
bull market is going to go on for until
maybe even
end of the year and considering that the
few models that have been correct
until now predict a 200 000 bitcoin
at the lower end in a 400 000 bitcoin at
the higher end
before the bull market ends
welcome to episode 98 of the michaela
peterson podcast
on today's episode i spoke with chris
zaknun
the ceo of dow maker a venture capital
crypto company
that invests in building safe and secure
frameworks for venture capital investing
that targets
everyday people who use blockchain
technology rather than just the usual
super rich folks who do venture capital
investing
chris shared his knowledge and
experience about cryptocurrencies
other than bitcoin and info on ethereum
and he offers a great deal of insight
for those who are new to the game
if you're like me and you want to learn
more about using crypto but not just
bitcoin
yeah i went there i still love you
bitcoin maximalists
but i'm an open human being so i needed
to see what the hubbub was about with
other tokens and cryptocurrencies
and blockchains this is definitely an
episode you won't want to miss if you
want to learn about how crypto
is infiltrating the entire world if you
enjoy this episode please consider
subscribing
and i'm wearing this much makeup because
i just took a headshot
against the wall with an iphone for my
upcoming
tedx talk enjoy this episode
[Music]
chris zak noon welcome to my podcast
thanks for being here it's an honor
awesome okay this is gonna be good i
have so many questions can we start off
by you giving a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
sure
so i'm here because probably i'm the ceo
of dell maker
um i got into crypto i think it's 2016
end of 2016
at the emergence of a new phenomena in
the space which was these icos
and pre-17 it was mainly about anarchy
or anarchists and libertarianism
and once icos came out there was a lot
more new coins right the crypto
what's i see what's the ic ico is a new
company
issuing a token as like a stock right
so there used to be mainly bitcoin and a
handful of bitcoin forks
bitcoin copies and then in 2017
everything exploded
and uh it was a bit of a cambric
explosion of the industry
and everything became much bigger a lot
more use cases for blockchain itself
up until that moment it was just
blockchain could be a store of value
a global currency network and then it
became the idea blockchain could be
supply chain blockchain could be so much
more a lot of companies started using
blockchain and a decentralized ledger
including a token to build their
business model
and that's exactly where i got in and i
got very passionate for these new
blockchain based startups
and i built my own company there's now
probably the number one in launching
these new
companies a bit like kickstarter for
these crypto based companies
okay why would a company bother making a
token sure
um in the beginning it was mainly
because of free money right it was a lot
of scams
just like any industry in the early days
it was just like let's grab as much
money it was really bad
in 2016-17 we saw 300
million dollar raises so the biggest one
being four billion dollars
essentially stolen right if you want to
know how to steal four billion dollars
that's one way of doing it then
everything became
calmer so now people do it for the right
reasons
so i think the reason you should have a
token
so you have it's because you have a
front a retail based
internet startup let's take facebook
right that's a
retail based internet startup let's say
you have a social network that has a
token
and a social network that does not have
a token now if you have a social network
and
the growth of that network somehow
reflects
in the price of the token then you have
two choices do i want to use
the network where i am on the owner or
where i am the product
because if i have if i own the token
then i can benefit from the growth
itself
i can invite my friends to this network
and i will get paid
and that's really the strongest argument
for why we believe that in the future a
lot of companies
at least retail-based companies will be
tokenized
okay let's dumb this down a little bit
why would why would you
get paid more if you have a token sure
because
if you use facebook right now you don't
own equity
right you the vcs on the equity you have
no benefit or no incentive to use a
network
other than it's fun right you like to
use the network on instagram because you
know you like the experience
but you are the product and everybody
knows nowadays that instagram is selling
the people
but you are not getting paid for being
sold but if you had a token
which is openly accessible to anybody
and you can just buy
then you can get something back for
being used as a product
one tiny bit in this gigantic network
so that's kind of like a stock it's kind
of like a stock which is
opened and permissionless stocks are
very regulated
you can't every not everybody can get it
you know it's like
imagine you would get facebook shares
for using facebook
that would be great that would be great
okay
let's back up a little bit i've had a
number of bitcoiners on the podcast and
i've never covered anything
other than bitcoin so let's just start
off with
what is ethereum sure what is a theorem
a theorem is essentially the the master
machine that people call it
now what's the difference between
bitcoin and ethereum
bitcoin is something called well b
ethereum is touring complete
and touring complete means it's a
programming language that allows you to
do
quite complicated um programming
things right touring is the guy who
invented the there's a famous movie
right invented the computer before the
computer you could do a lot of
computations such as a calculator and
basic stuff
simple math but after they invented the
computer
you were able to do quite complex things
so if a comp if a language is true and
complete it allows you to do
quite interesting things other than just
sending money back and forth
however it invites problems because it
adds more complexity
more complexity means if i make a simple
mistake in the code which i didn't think
about
and have a few million dollars in that
code it's just gone
the reason that bitcoin is not to
incomplete is because they want to keep
it super super simple
so that they become the global value
network
and these are the two main differences
between these two things
okay so why would anybody be on ethereum
if you can
potentially hack it versus bitcoin yes
it's because you can do more complex
things
right you cannot do a lot of things you
know on bitcoin you like do this
go there do that it's very simple but in
ethereum you can do
anything you want using any programming
language you can build a game
you can't build a game of bitcoin you
can build a lot of stuff
and this is essentially what we now know
as smart contracts
smart contract is essentially a
unbreakable contract
if the code is correct an unbreakable
contract is between you and me
so let's say we have an agreement on a
contract based
that you have to pay me every month now
you can break that contract
but you cannot break a smart contract i
don't need to trust a lawyer i don't
need to trust anybody
because we both looked at the code and
the code says you will send me on a
specific day
specific amount of money and the code
cannot be changed
because the code is on the blockchain so
we both trust
that nobody on the blockchain is going
to change our agreement
that piece of code that simply says you
send money on the fifth
of every month to this wallet
and you can make contact okay okay
so so you could i'm not very well versed
in this i'm learning
but you could set up a business and if
you were paying people in cryptocurrency
that could be automated without
accountants and lawyers exactly
because the people trust the code
and more importantly they trust that the
code is unstoppable
and unchangeable because just like you
cannot
reverse a bitcoin transaction you cannot
change the code so you know that if this
person
wrote this you just it just said it just
does its thing forever
until you run out of money and that's it
right it depends on what is written in
this more complex
code which cannot be written on bitcoin
right smart contracts are not able to be
deployed on bitcoin because the language
itself
is too basic so you cannot say
on the fifth of something and it just
does not have support for these things
okay so when people buy ethereum are
they basically
for lack of a better description buying
stock in the ethereum platform as
you know a mode of doing a whole bunch
of business oriented things that you
can't do on other platforms
so what's the business model of ethereum
so there's let's start with these two
things
what is why do people buy bitcoin you
know buy bitcoin
because it's it's all about narrative
which means
what do they believe is going to happen
in the future and how does it plan
the bitcoin narrative is this is going
to be
digital gold you hear this statement all
the time
because it's super decentralized proof
of work is very secure
it is very simple and it's exactly all
the things it needs to be
to do that one thing that global
network of wealth and as all other fiat
currencies
die bitcoin will stay secure and simple
and do that one thing and do it really
good which is
essentially being a value a store of
value
but ethereum is different ethereum is
essentially a
blockchain that provides security as a
service to other companies my company
for example
our token is built on ethereum now
if we want to have a token which can be
freely traded
we cannot have all the miners building
their whole thing
just to secure our network and make sure
that nobody double spins
so we can piggyback on ethereum
they will provide the security that the
miners have built up
for our token we have our own token on
their network
and we don't have to worry about anybody
double spending meaning
stop duplicating the code that's the
whole invention of blockchain
blockchain makes things digital not
copyable
which is a huge thing and we piggyback
ethereum as a security and in exchange
when we
send our token we have to pay some kind
of tax
for a theorem called gas which is paid
in the theorem
and the reason the theorem has value is
because a lot of people who want to use
a
have to own ethereum to pay the tax
and in exchange if your provides
security
okay that's very cool that's a very
interesting way of putting it
this episode is brought to you by true
local yes i'm back in canada
finally able to enjoy my true local meat
again to local partners with local
farmers and butchers in your area
to source the best meat and deliver it
to your door
they really care about quality and
sustainability and if you're feeling
guilty about eating meat
this is the company to go with i know
most of my audience probably doesn't
but if you do or if you don't even i
still love these guys
i recommend their grain-fed beef wild
salmon and their lamb is some of the
best i've ever had
they have over a hundred different cuts
of meat that you probably can't find at
your grocery store
to get started go to true local
t-r-u-local dot ca
for canadians or t-r-u-local usa.com for
americans to build your own personalized
box oh meat it shows up at your door
vacuum sealed and individually portioned
which is perfect for meal prep by an air
fryer seriously
seriously guys and just throw those
steaks in frozen unwrap them first
use code mp to get free steak in your
order
at trulocal.ca or trulocalusa.com
codemp for free steaks i hope you're
enjoying the episode
like i said i've been talking to maitly
so why here here's another question
why do bitcoiners in general never talk
about other cryptocurrencies
like why are these so separated sure
because
the bitcoin maximus argument is that
essentially the believers
there will only be one layer of value on
the internet
just like there's only one internet
they come from the belief that the only
use case for blockchain
is to be a decentralized store value
on a global level everything else does
not
need blockchain so it's just a scam
because you could build the same thing
on a database
all right so this is essentially an
opinion view
that comes down to that one belief that
you do not need blockchain for anything
else
than this global internet value
because in order to use blockchain it
has to be super simple because otherwise
it's not really decentralized
the reason money should be truly
decentralized is because if anybody has
the power
they will abuse it sooner or later and
we've seen this over millennials
so that one piece of power that nobody
should possess
and everybody can agree that nobody
should possess
is the global value just like u.s
currently has
more or less the power of manipulating
global value because most people
use a dollar standard so they're abusing
it right they're paying a lot of money
to maintain
trading routes that suspend the dollar
value so they can print the dollar
and essentially ensuring like slowly
taxing everybody who's using the dollar
so stealing everybody kind of agrees
that that's the one thing
nobody should have right nobody should
be that powerful
and everything else is not so important
we can use in a database
okay and is that wrong like could we
just be building databases
well yes and no right it can't be wrong
if so many people have been in the space
for so long come to the same conclusion
right
however it is a kind of a false
assumption
it is an ideology more than anything
else
it's not really business perspective a
business evolves
out of unique selling points
that's if you have a unique selling
point an advantage
that is cost effective against the
competition then your
your unique selling point is going to
evolve you know just like evolution
so a token by itself can be a unique
selling point
because it can give these people small
people this
little aspect of ownership in this
company in this value creation and you
can do cool stuff of it
you can provide positive feedback loops
so let's say we take it back to the
facebook example
you own a tiny you own some part of
token of facebook and let's say
some of the ad revenue goes back to the
token okay
so you have this money you have like
your bag of your back of facebook
and you want that bag to grow so what
you do you tell your friends hey you
know
come on facebook and he's like it's so
good you're not going to tell me if back
but you're going to just like
essentially be incentivized to grow the
network
if everybody's incentivized to grow the
network we have a massive network effect
so even though the ideology behind why
bitcoin has a token or blockchain is
decentralized does not apply to tokens
does not mean tokens are useless
okay so it's kind of like
this is this is a stretch but it's kind
of like if you put a product an online
product out online and you make
an affiliate code and you send that to a
whole bunch of people and you say hey
you're going to take 15 of whatever you
sell
it's the same kind of idea right because
then it just grows by itself because
you're sharing the wealth
yes in some way it is like this just
that you cannot cut it out
it's just inside the system but there's
one more difference
someone else is giving up 15 to give it
to you
that's not how it works right everybody
wins collectively
by everybody having a little bit less
yeah but what they have is worth more
and that's why this is essentially
called a dow a decentralized autonomous
organization
the idea of restructuring governance in
a system like bitcoin
but that's too far i don't want to go
into there that is so cool
okay okay
so i have some let's get into dow maker
a little bit
and then i'm going to ask some other
questions
but what what is dow maker and what does
dow maker do
i'd say dial maker is still a startup so
it's always hard to
identify what we will be and what we are
right now
but i'd say the most closest analogy
would be we are somewhat of a y
combinator of the crypto industry
so we take for people who don't know
what y combinator is it's a very famous
incubator
they take they incubated the airbnb i
think they incubated a bunch of other
very famous companies
so they take intelligent people with big
dreams
and they help them solve the problems
that they need to scale up
and build these value-adding services
that we all came to be used to
now we are running this as a business so
big people who want to build
something in blockchain some kind of
financial
instrument whatever like a lot of
different stuff
they come to us and we make sure that
they are not lost in the wild west right
i used to like this industry is still
quite
complex and dangerous and if you don't
know what you're going to do
you're just going to get shot
metaphorically speaking so we're a bit
like we
we help these tourists who are coming
from the traditional world who are very
smart who want to build something in the
space
using their knowledge and other
knowledge we make sure they don't get
shot
before they become too big we just hold
them by the hand
and ensuring that all their problems are
solved so that they can
focus on fixing the problem that they
went out to
fix can you give me an example of
um some startup that you guys helped
along
sure um we've been doing this for four
years so
collectively now the sum of all the
startups that we helped is now i think
eight billion dollars so i've been quite
extensive at this i think the network
that we helped is
quite huge it's also important to state
that the funding of this
is something that's very important this
goes to the people so up until reece up
until
very recently like two three years there
was billions of dollars given to a
handful of
venture capitals people rich we come in
and we say
why don't you sell to your users because
the users will be the ones which will
actually help you a lot
venture capitals which is the people who
found airbnbs etc they will just give
you mentorship
so eight billion dollars through growth
of startups
have been given to small people around
the world through the help of dow maker
that's really where we identify
ourselves we try to bring new startups
that were never able that you were never
able to invest in
as a small guy like you would never be
able to get into facebook right it was
like up here you would not
not get into it and we bring these
things down
and tell the companies up here these
people are not useless
and we find the good people who are
helping and holding
and bring them to the companies so one
example for that would be example
l-run network which is its own
blockchain which focuses on very fast
transactions
um another one would be for example ryan
most of the companies in in the crypto
industry are based on finances
we have a huge problem in the industry
which is segmentation of
trading exchanges there's nasdaq in new
york stock exchange
we have these things in crypto and these
all segmented
because no one found a way to bring them
all together
and one of the companies which figured
out how to do this
is called the ryan network i think it's
now i don't know half a billion dollar
company
we made a few hundred more billion
dollar companies but i don't want to go
too much into detail
because these are very crypto related
subjects
okay how risky is it for people you said
that you're bringing
like smaller people in who wouldn't
necessarily be
available to be or a venture capitalist
you're bringing these people in to
invest in these crypto startups so
how risky is it for these individuals so
usually we cap meaning we maximize their
investment amount at
one thousand two thousand dollars so
they can't
put more in than that now some people
that's all they have but some people put
a lot more
because crypto is super risky and super
dangerous so we cap this and distributes
the risk amongst a lot of people
no one can lose more than five hundred
one thousand dollars
the next thing is in the current market
which is
quite bullish you know bitcoin went from
5k
if you like almost like four months ago
to now 30k went down by 70
but it's still up tremendously it is
near impossible
to lose money with these startups as of
right now
statistically speaking
however as market sentiment changes
because the crypto market sees a long
bull market
and then there's kind of game of thrones
winter you know which lasts for multiple
years and everything is ice age and
everything just dries out
so in these periods which usually lasts
not very long these summers
it's very safe in the winter which is
predominantly most of the time
it is quite risky and during these
periods of time we usually provide our
users a refund policy of up to 50
so all they can lose is 50 of their
money
okay how long do you think this bull
market is gonna last
that's the question on everybody's mind
yeah
well there's a difference right because
bitcoin currently is
super bullish we hear so much good news
about bitcoin all the time coming out
now
um even though it crashed right
fundamentally bitcoin has never
been more positive than right now
which is because of institutions trying
to see that their inflation is very high
you know it's like two three percent of
the dollar a month
and they wanna find some way to stable
out their balance sheet
so you put one or two percent to bitcoin
so i can see that the bitcoin
bull market is going to go on for until
maybe even
end of the year and considering that the
few models that have been correct
until now predict a
200 000 bitcoin at the lower end
in a 400 000 bitcoin at the higher end
before the bull market ends which i can
believe
however when it comes to the lower caps
they have been damaged quite a bit um
now maybe if people heard that there was
been a lot of hate towards elon musk
not because of the whole tesla bitcoin
thing but
because of the whole dogecoach dogecoin
thing yeah
yeah coin is is like a a coin that was
invented to make fun of cryptocurrencies
and it is it was meant as a scam right
it was meant as like oh put money here i
will steal it from you
so and then it just became a whole thing
because community matters and it's great
and people like dogs
and that's all good and right that you
support dogs
i also love dogs there's one right
behind me
but not if you're as influential as elon
musk
because as a result of this we saw a
massive pandemic encrypt of
scams all types of dog coins and scam
coins
because people say well if elon musk he
knows what he's doing he's endorsing
this
i can put my money into these scams
coins too and
billions of dollars were stolen of
people
who would have put money into all good
companies
whereas the people who would buy bitcoin
which is many institutions were unharmed
so what i'm saying is i believe that the
bitcoin
bull market is going to last
several more months maybe to end of the
year however the
smaller coins might will might crash
even more than they currently are
okay what's the difference between like
something like dogecoin
and the dow maker coin sure
so let's take a technical look at it and
some other things
dogecoin is a fork a copy paste
of bitcoin so it can't do much right it
can just be a coin
just like bitcoin can only be a coin by
design that's so good
dolores coin can just be a coin
dowel maker is built on ethereum so
we're piggybacking the security
theorem dogecoin has its own thing it's
all security right it's all miners etc
um next well i guess that really sums it
up dogecoin is meant as a currency
whereas dollmaker is meant as a
tokenized share
of the dalmaker company doubtmaker has
benefits you know our coin gives you
certain benefits
if you own these coins for example you
own this coin you have a
chance of getting into these sales which
generally make
money not all of them they're risky but
in the bull market generally speaking
they all make money dogecoin gives you
no benefits right
it just goes up if you don't tweets
about it
okay is there a difference between a
token and a coin
yes so what's the difference right
that's a common question
a token is built in a blockchain that
provides security for it
whereas a coin has to provide its own
security through proof of stake
or proof of work okay
and for people who don't know can you
describe what proof of stake and proof
of work are
sure so proof of work is considered the
secure version it's when the miners have
their law machines
and their the asics the graphic cards
and they're solving problems right these
terms are basically
which object do i put through a machine
and a number comes out they don't know
what
they know the number but they don't know
what the object is so they have to send
these objects through the machine until
they guess the right number
it sounds a bit stupid it also is a bit
stupid but it makes sense in the grand
scheme of things
so eventually they find out that this
object represents this number and they
got bitcoin
that's the whole game what's an example
of an object what do you mean by object
object is just a number right they put a
number in and through this machine
they get a different number out they
don't know what number they have to put
in the machine to get this number
but they know if i get this number i get
some bitcoin it's about 10 bitcoin a day
so proof of stake the idea of proof of
work is one thing
electricity is universal it's a
universal measurement
of value throughout everywhere right
suns
galaxies humans we all have some kind of
use of electricity
so therefore using if we use up this
electricity
we give up a fundamental value to create
a bitcoin
and somehow like moving that fundamental
value to bitcoin
converting these two things over
throughout the whole universe so it's
considered as a very stable thing
proof of stake is more based on
one idea everything in crypto
tries to avoid people stopping to copy
digital stuff that's the basis right if
i have one bitcoin and i can copy two
bitcoins it's not a good bitcoin right
because i can just make infinite money
the whole point is 21 million bitcoin
because it makes this whole scarcity
thing so everything tries to make sure
that people do not copy
the coins that's the one thing bitcoin
make sure that
they don't copy the coin is because
people buy the miners
cost a lot of money because of
electricity and if they would all
collude together
and be like oh let's make bitcoin 40
million and not 21 million
they can and if they all reach agreement
that they want to change the code
they're just like
backslash bash lagging 21 to 40. they
could
change this number as long as they all
agree on it
but if they would agree on it and they
would change the number then all the
money they spend into their machines
is wasted because bitcoin is worthless
okay now proof of stake is almost the
same thing but instead of having actual
machines
where they have to put extra money in
they take the coin they have the coin
they stake it
and if they make if they start colluding
and do something they're not supposed to
the coin goes down value which is not
good for them because they have a lot of
it
they lose a lot of money so they're
incentivized to do the right thing
okay okay uh let's switch directions
slightly
for people why would a regular business
like you said brick and mortar
or let's say brick and mortar because i
know you guys are doing some work with
this why would a
like a regular business adopt some sort
of blockchain
product or why would they put anything
on the blockchain what's the point of
even
being involved in the blockchain let's
choose a bottle right like a fancy
green bottle business yeah well
the straight honest truth is they don't
have much benefit right
most blockchain stuff is based on
finances
or um internet
you know businesses social media
finances etc
having a hardcore like physical product
does not really benefit from blockchain
i don't think that it makes sense in
that sense
they could make up a bunch of [ __ ]
saying oh we have
this blockchain and it's these bottles
are
green and we have the entire supply
chain that we know that you can rest we
will recycle bottles
and we can prove this on a blockchain
and you can
see all of it you know there's a lot of
examples of wine for example people like
wine
they want to know where the wine comes
from so they use a blockchain
to make sure that they cannot just
change a nominal database and corrupt
everything
so you see that the wine
is coming from the grapes in north spain
and not somewhere else
but that's pretty much it okay and
how would so say you have a company
let's say a wine company and you want to
give people the information about where
your grapes came from
when they buy the bottle of wine how
accessible is it for the average
consumer to get that information if it's
on the blockchain like do they need some
sort of
app to just access that information yeah
there's
other blockchain products that build
these apps and work with the wine
companies
so that you have an app you scan it and
you know that nobody has the ability of
lying to you
so if you don't trust the wine company
or let's take meat
right meat is a good topic because if
meat is rot or anything you get real big
problems
so governments could use a blockchain
because they don't trust all the meat
producers
so put a lot of effort have a lot of
tenders be like okay
a lot of regulation to making sure that
you are now approved to be selling meat
would be much easier if anybody could do
this the problem is you don't trust the
guy
right so it takes a lot of regulation
until you trust that meat producer
using blockchain you take out the trust
because they cannot give you a fake
database
so on the blockchain they can change the
data
okay yeah yeah so
that makes sense so the problem right
now and i think
this the reason that this hasn't been
more widespread because the idea behind
this is is really smart like that seems
like something that's going to spread
so i think part of the reason it hasn't
spread is because for the average person
understanding this is really difficult
it's like
you know having a computer in 1990
yeah like or trying to build one right
and now we're just given an ipad and you
don't have to understand anything about
the ipad
so the user experience in regards to
anything that's blockchain related is
really complicated
so do you like do you think there's a
timeline
how long do you think it's going to take
for like the user experience to be
a little bit simplified for the average
person or
yeah well i'm not sure if it actually
gets much better i've been in the space
for a long time
it got a little bit it got a little bit
better yes but it should have gotten
much better than it did
i believe that gaming and generation z
will
really get into crypto and maybe the
older generation is going to kind of
grow out of it
because when you game all day long you
kind of get used to internet currencies
right
and i probably see that cryptocurrencies
will be hugely adopted in games
because would you play a game where your
money is real or would you want to play
a game where your money's fake
it's like i spend real money yeah you
get i spend like my
time in this game i get paid for it
right and then i think that the kids who
will
get real currencies they will be in
they will have apps in their phones and
then tell their parents it will go
upwards
usually it's downwards then we also see
a lot of adoption from huge companies
samsung and so on they provide the
wallets
for the most basic layer which is just
money
right we will not see any adoption of
blockchain stuff
before people didn't just get
cryptocurrencies like the money
use case people need to be comfortable
with not using a bank
and then maybe like this is super super
early still
all these experimental blockchain things
need to know how to get used to money i
do believe that
once big phone companies will just
integrate a wallet
it's gonna get very fast okay that makes
sense you said something about samsung
integrating
a wallet yeah i think a lot of companies
integrating wallets
um twitter is being very much bitcoin
maximalist
so they're using something called
lightning wallet which makes bitcoin
super fast
gonna integrate this so i believe that a
lot of big
companies one step one is
money inflation step two is let's buy
some bitcoin in our balance sheet
right suddenly they have a bag and the
back example always works
now they're like oh i have this bag what
what can i do to pump this bag well i
can use my huge corporation to integrate
some bitcoin
to make my bitcoin go up that's how
bitcoin gets
more and more adopted so you will see
the big guys the powerful guys slowly
getting into bitcoin
and then realizing that they have the
power to increase the value of their own
coin just like
you win the facebook example it's the
one powerful use case of tokens
what kind of con what countries around
the world are implementing
cryptocurrencies right now
do you know well the big news is that el
salvador made
bitcoin a legal tender which basically
means it made it a legal
currency and they're requiring shops to
accept which is a big deal
right because they're like okay we're
getting screwed over by the dollar and
they're printing it out so
what can we do we don't have the
economic mass to enforce our own fiat
currency no one's gonna use it
they don't trust it they're like okay we
have two choices do we choose bitcoin or
do we choose
getting screwed over by bit by dollar so
they chose bitcoin
then there's different countries which
say which are okay
on bitcoin right um you your eu is okay
on bitcoin japan is okay on bitcoin
south like most of asia besides china's
okay and bitcoin and then there's a
company
countries which are not okay another
case like
china constantly bans bitcoin and the us
is like it's questionable what they're
gonna do
because for one they're very democratic
country and if they start banning
bitcoin
it will reflect very badly on their
image it's as simple as that right
they're like
you cannot actually outsource this
currency which is supposed to give you
like freedom
in the land of the free so obviously
they don't like it so right now they're
in the situation we're like okay what
the [ __ ] do we do
at the same time they know that by that
china banned
bitcoin and china is also the biggest
market for bitcoin
so we have enough data to show if a
country bans bitcoin
it will just promote bitcoin the use of
it
interesting so
okay okay how's el salvador supposed to
collect taxes
are they are they just they've just
given up on that well the tax system on
bitcoin
it's actually if you build a structure
into it it's much much easier to tax
bitcoin than anything else
because it's all on the blockchain it's
all transparent
you can see that this shop has this
wallet and if they don't use this wallet
then they get in trouble um i don't
think they've figured it out so far yet
but i haven't done enough research maybe
they made it
theoretically you could somehow keep an
eye on people's wallets though right
stores wallets and then just
a certain perspective bitcoin that came
in there's a lot of people who tax
bitcoin people have been taxing bitcoin
for years
especially if you're american because
irs is on your ass
so it's not like everybody who has
bitcoin is a tax evader it's not true at
all
but but the taxing only comes into play
when you pull it out right into fiat
well that depends on different countries
so for example germany is a big one
it says if you hold a bitcoin for more
than one year you don't have to pay
taxes
most okay most countries take the
approach
you don't have to tax it until we can
tax it that's like
taking it out because it like taking it
out it's like oh there's some money
that's taxed
so yeah but the germany approach is like
okay
just hold bitcoin because we don't want
to tax it's too complicated for us
and i think the u.s is like no you have
to actually
state capital gain tax on all your
crypto
and they're working very close with
coinbase the biggest crypto exchange in
the us
but i'm not an expert in this okay
if people want to get started
how do you suggest they do that what do
they do
you have to learn uh no let's say let's
say other cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin we've already been over
bitcoin my audience should know about
bitcoin
like more likely involved in other
currencies well usually they go down the
rabbit hole
and then they end up losing all their
money
that's usually what happens so how do
people should get started if they want
to go okay why does that
wait wait let's back up a little bit why
does that happen like why do people end
up losing their money
because of greed because they get more
and more greedy
and the more greedy you get the easiest
way to steal money is to
tell them that you could they to abuse
their grade right that's
basis of every scam it's like it's too
good to be true
well it's not so let's take this in a
specific example we started bitcoin and
you're like oh i'm holding my bitcoin
and my bitcoin goes up five percent and
you're like oh my bitcoin went up five
percent and you're like super happy
because you used to have like a zero
point one percent of the bank for a
whole year so you're like super happy
and then you see over there eve was like
ten percent of all
i wanted ten percent so they go over to
eve and then they like holding the eve
and then they go like to the smaller
coins
and they see some news because now
they're learning about crypt on twitter
right and they they see the stuff in
their news feed
and they see this coin pumped by fifty
percent they're like oh my god i only
had this 10
this [ __ ] guy got 50 so they jump
over there and now they're already like
in the
medium caps which are still pretty safe
right they're like the blue chips
they're not the super safe one but
they're still the blue chips
and now they find out about all the
crazy yield opportunities
which is essentially just a ponzi scheme
you put money into it
and then you get more token in exchange
of buying the token so you can kind of
see where it goes
and you get like a thousand five hundred
percent returns a year
which is like boom and then they're like
okay i want to do this
because they don't know what they don't
know anything better because they never
learned about inflation they never
learned about monetary policies
they don't understand that if you
inflate the coin by thousand five
hundred percent to a thousand people
it's gonna be worthless real fast and
that's what happens
now they they agreed ended up with them
having from one bitcoin
to having a ton of these worthless coins
because they just went to zero
and that usually takes three months
and then okay most of them say this is
all scam and they come back three years
later
and the same thing happens again but
some of them get smarter
they admit that it was their own great
that they can learn
and this is an interesting opportunity
for them and they slowly
work themselves back so what's the
proper way to do it
not don't do that but what's the proper
way to do it
well it's like is good advice advice
that is good
or is good and is good advice advice
that people actually listen to
which is okay you know what i mean
and it's like should i tell people what
they should do but i know they're not
gonna follow it
or should i tell people what is slightly
worse but they might actually do it
and it comes down to what should they do
and what will they do
we dow maker provided the service which
is safe
and we will know they will do it anybody
who comes new to crypto
they love this they love the strategy
because we give them like what they
agreed
in a safe environment um but it's hard
to get in that's why it's a lottery
because it's what everybody wants
everybody once can't be opened right
otherwise inflation
boom i think people should definitely
stick to like
the coinbase coins that's why coinbase
has the structure they have
right they don't provide their people
things that
are horrible that's their business model
they're like
we're only going to put stuff on our
platform which is big you know it can't
crash has a certain amount of
market value so that our users which are
very much
noobs can play in a safe environment
so if people stick to this then they
should be fine if they want to do like
the crazy stuff
you have to learn and just study just
like anything else right you learn
you go to high school and school so that
you know the
dangers or whatever of life if you just
jump into an opportunity where you have
no idea about you're probably going to
get right
that's fair uh how do you feel about
these coins that i can't remember who
that celebrities make so i remember it
was logan or jake paul
will come up with a coin and they'll say
you know anybody buy this coin
okay are they nfts or coins i thought i
saw a coin being produced
well these are the fan tokens right
there's a bunch of fan tokens like big
football companies have
big fan tokens well it's a bit like
dogecoin right
it's i would call it a community coin um
if the intentions are good then it could
make sense
right because it's all about the
intention if
let's i don't know if it's i don't think
it's logan paul i don't even know his
jake paul let's just call him
mr x i don't want to say anything bad
about any person
so mr x has 95 of the token supply
and he pumps up the last five percent up
to the moon and it dumps well obviously
it's dangerous
but if it's a coin which is given out to
everybody
and for your fan base for whatever
reason
it could help because it can help your
brand and you can build a business model
into it and you can always tap into this
i have a
i have a bag of tokens i want to pump my
bag
how do i pump my back wallet by helping
him grow followers
so you can always tap into this feedback
loop of that every coin has
the main the main reason bitcoin is so
huge is because
you buy bitcoin you're like okay you
should buy a bitcoin too
because if you buy bitcoin my bitcoin
goes up in price and then you get the
network effect
so these community tokens could benefit
this
but generally most of them are money
grabs
most of them are very dangerous and end
up with everybody losing all their money
okay and the reason for that is because
whoever's kind of in charge of the coin
is holding a whole bunch of it so as
soon as it grows in value they just
take they just like print the money and
the money goes down in value
so they end up with the real money and
you end up with like [ __ ]
you end up like this fake token okay
okay so that's why a whole bunch of
these things are scams that makes sense
so i guess the use of
the use of ethereum in the blockchain
potentially could be used
partly to pay employees without having a
finance
structure regardless of where the
employee is
but potentially you could yeah you could
do that with bitcoin too though right
no because the ability that you can code
it's called bitcoin script
it's the bitcoin programming language
solidity is the name of the firm
programming language does not provide
the necessary
flexibility to do much you can do
pretty little on it on purpose right
because the more
things you can do the more things can go
wrong
and that can't happen right it has to be
the global currency interplanetary
currency has to be super simple
okay that makes sense then you can't
code in that you want your employees
paid at a certain time
per month and ah exactly but you could
on ethereum
yes that's actually how these two things
happen right
the founders the founders of ethereum
were
big bitcoin fans and they said we should
build this and they had disagreements
and they said we just do our own thing
made the firm it's actually quite funny
the story is that the guy who invented
the firm which i think 27 now
was about 22 when he made the theorem
i heard this is not confirmed there's a
bit maybe even rumor
he was a big world of warcraft player
and he played a lot of time on the game
to make the sword
and then they deleted the sword and he's
like well that shouldn't happen right
that can't happen they can't just change
a code like i had an agreement that i
put my time in i do the quest i get the
[ __ ] code
i get the sword so he's like let's fix
this [ __ ] problem so that doesn't
happen again
and that's a good example right in the
game if you do this this and this you
will get the sword nobody can change
you will have this sword forever which
would be an nft
that's cool okay this is so fascinating
this is so different than
uh than like not real world examples
it's just a different way of thinking
than
than normal it's not the real world
finance
yeah it's fascinating
but it can be implemented like there are
i can see how it could be implemented
and how people could find it useful
especially if you end up
giving kind of not stock
to like people who have your product but
kind of yes that makes
so much sense that's our business model
right we find
companies that can benefit from this
whole i have a bag
i want to push it up by helping the
company
that's for me the best thing about
bitcoin and i saw it and i said okay we
can use this
for anything
yeah and then why wouldn't you want to
invest in a company where you own stock
rather than
spending your time on a company that
potentially provides the same
opportunity but doesn't give you any
stock yep
interesting that's a usb right that's a
unique selling point that will dominate
anything else
yeah okay uh
let me see we covered dogecoin i wanted
to cover that
how do you choose companies to kind of
incubate on dow maker
sure so we have a approach where we take
companies live that we have a specific
time frame for it
and based on that we take a look at what
do they provide do they provide
infrastructure
meaning do other people build on them
like ethereum
has huge potential if it's
infrastructure means it can be gigantic
or does it have a specific small use
case that will probably be easy to
implement
so we kind of choose different types
like okay this is gonna be like four
years of work this is gonna be like
six months of work the next thing we do
is
we say well our job really is to make
sure that people don't get scammed
we're like a gatekeeper in the sense of
like scams
and since we started doing this and all
of other competitors started doing it
we're really seeing a lot less scams
because people can easily send money
to an ico a tokenized startup
and nobody can stop them from sending
money
on crypto from one address to another
it's like this this nigerian prince
right but people are kind of i don't
know
stupid they just do it anyway in crypto
so the first thing that's really
important is like
is this company legit like who are the
people behind it we have a talk of them
we try to screen them we try to be like
what are your intentions like are you
doing this so you can grab a bunch of
money
are you doing this this way we try to
understand what is their time frame like
are they gonna give up in six months if
time gets tough
that's really the most important thing
are you gonna tr are you
interested in your token that's the
second thing because you can have the
best company in the world
but if you neglect that token it's still
a scam
because you're raising money right
you're collecting money you're like okay
i give you this and you give me and i
keep so you give me your money and i
give you the fake money
because my belief in my company in me
trying to make your fake money not fake
is what matters
because every tokenized startup starts
as fake money
the harder i work the less fake it gets
that's the second thing we try to get in
and then the third thing is like does it
even have
the ability of not becoming fake like is
there a
value add like is there a way
that this business can create value
extract value
and store it in their coin because if
they can happen the better the business
does
the better the coin does and very
important is is this coin
is the growth of this coin connected to
the business because then there's a
positive feedback loop and once we have
this positive feedback loop
our coins start annihilating the
competition because it's like oh
a well-designed system and these are the
three things right
that we really look for okay
that makes sense uh what do you think
about bitcloud
big cloud well there's a lot of bits on
things
but i know bitcloud yeah it's been this
old one right
it's like i think it's this from what
i've seen on the outside
it it puts people on there and then you
can kind of invest into the coin behind
the person not that the person has
anything to do with the coin
but uh it's like democratizing humans
right
yeah it's like you can buy some of
someone isn't it this
yeah well how do you ensure that this
person will just
like what does that even mean because a
smart contract is
only good if it's digital the moment you
stop crossing the digital world
i cannot build a smart contract to make
you
send me apples because that just doesn't
work right
i can make you send me digital apples
it has to be within the digital world if
it's outside digital world then a smart
contract cannot
enforce this guy to do anything so
there's actually no
security it does not guarantee
the trust between this person that you
just bought
and him right
so in other words is let's say i
buy 10 of your share of whatever you do
you make this podcast podcast make some
money
how do i know how much money the podcast
makes how do i ensure that there's
how that you're lying to me about the
revenue streams maybe it's like a
extremely
non-profit business because you have all
kinds of expenses how do i
make you send me the money and there's
so many questions
smart contracts need to be super simple
you have money here
send me on that date here until it runs
out
as soon as it gets more complicated it
doesn't work
what if what if the coins that let me
see if i can get this right
what if so on bitcoin on bitcloud you
invest theoretically and you invest into
a person
what if that person was just treated
like a community-based coin
so rather than giving any money back it
just grows in value
that's essentially the same thing right
now
the reason the community first of all
most community based coins are scams
like let's say 92 or like 98.
so the only reason these other two
percent are not scammed
is because the person is issuing it is
staking his reputation
he's like if i i made this coin
you all know me i have this reputation
which
converts into real money because your
reputation people want to do business
with you
if i start scamming you now i'm losing
my reputation because i staked it
with this coin because you all know that
i'm a scammer now i will never be
in business so that's the reason why
these other like five or ten percent of
community coins
will not are not scams because like okay
you know me i've been here if i start
scamming i'm dead right
my business my life whatever i build is
gone
whereas with these people in bitcloud
you don't know who they are they're
nobodies right
that's why you buy them because you buy
to invest in them
interesting okay okay last question
if people want to get involved
what apps are available now to make it a
little bit easier to
figure out how to use ethereum sure well
the most famous one is probably coinbase
which is super user friendly
if they want to be a bit more
adventurous and risky they can go on
finance
which has a lot more options oh i see
that's why it's riskier
it's riskier because it's not regulated
one
and it's riskier because there's a lot
of options and the business model is not
really to protect the people
whereas coinbase is ethos is like we
need to
protect the people because we need the
people to grow the industry and while we
grow the industry we will become the
biggest
completely two different ethos finance
is more like okay
cut throat business as soon as new
opportunity we jump on it [ __ ] the
people and it works right both of them
are pretty powerful
i think buying it's the fastest growing
unicorn in the in the history of
humanity
wow i didn't know that um
so these are two apps that anybody can
use there's a lot of apps
where for example binance coinbase.com
learn or earn i think it's earn you can
learn about crypto
and earn crypto so then you can like
learn about stuff
and earn crypto and then lose that at
least you didn't put your own money into
it
you can do that for a few weeks and then
you can put your own money into it but
people won't do that they will just be
like okay i have a thousand bucks
i put it here now i have 500. now i sell
it's the first rule of crypto it's like
buy high sell low
okay okay what about um
so coinbase and finance you can buy
bitcoin on there as well yeah yeah you
can buy a lot on
finance how do you feel about kraken
kraken is an old very expensive company
right
now you always have to think if i make a
trade okay how much do i pay for this
trade
reason people like binance is because
it's like 0.005 percent
it's like almost nothing so you always
have to think if this coin
i have to if i pay one percent then it
has to go up one percent in price
just for me to make my money back so
kraken
super legit super old quite expensive
and you make a few trades you already
made lost five ten percent of your money
yeah because every time it's like one
one two you know after five trades five
percent gone
i'm not sure it's one percent i don't
think it's one percent it's a bit absurd
but maybe half a percent
okay okay so coinbase and then what
about things like metamask
well metamask is the hero alright of the
industry
because you can just plug it into your
browser and you
unleash the decentralized nature of the
industry
it's a bit like tor right be careful
there's a lot of opportunities but you
are if you use matter mask you are now
unprotected at the same time you are now
fully crypto the whole point of crypto
is that you are unprotected you are
responsible for yourself um
but you can do anything lots of
opportunities
to make money and a ton of opportunities
to get scammed
got it it's a little bit more risky
there um what do you think about
tara i've heard things about tara i love
tara
the reason why people love terra is
because for a long time
ethereum was the god of all
blockchain applications right so there's
bitcoin there's ethereum there's like
some dogecoin litecoin and some other
stuff
and then there's this universe of
companies and 98
of them maybe 99 are all built on
ethereum so that's like a crazy monopoly
at the moment terra was the first
company to build something like ethereum
and kind of make if you're in bleed by
building two or three applications
which were super super popular faster
cheaper better and people like that
because if taro is the first company to
be like okay
ethereum is good but we can do it better
than them and that caused
a lot of blockchains to become very
aggressive because once you make the god
bleed
you can see he maybe can kill him
okay that's interesting so what makes
okay and then
last question then i'll let you go
what's the difference between ethereum
and ethereum 2.0
well the one exists the other one is is
a theory
so if theorem 2.0 a lot of if your
lovers will hate me for saying this is
the dip the main differences
the one is proof of work which is like
the miners doing their thing
staking this universal unit of of energy
and the other one is proof-of-stake
meaning they stake ethereum
so if they do anything bad this year and
price goes down
the reason that you need to build this
on proof-of-stake
is because people work very expensive
very slow you cannot build transactions
because on ethereum if you write a line
of codes be like hello world it's a very
famous line of code
you pay per line of code a little bit of
a theorem
so you write a code which has like 300
lines of code you really pay like 2 000
bucks
because you pay for every single line
that you write so the solution
ethereum language is like kind of long
and summed up
this is not sustainable because it was
not built
for it and they're trying to change it
now to something else
the problem is it's a bit like the
analogy i like to use
a lot of people disagree is like you are
on a
a boeing 747 with one
engine left and the all others already
broken and smoking
and you're trying to repair the other
engines
in mid flight while
everybody who has the ability to repair
the engine is completely against
repairing the engine because it's not
there's an incentive to do so
i personally do not believe in ethereum
2.0 because it doesn't make much sense
but if europe needs to maintain people
to keep telling them that it's something
in the future because right now it
doesn't work
it does not work at all you have to pay
like 100
to make one trade it's not possible
right if you're right now is like this
this imaginary thing
which will never really scale unless
you're super rich
so they need to tell people i believe
that right that's just speculation
a lie that they can look forward to so
that they don't die
even though their death is inedible like
it's going to be terra
it's going to be solana it's going to be
someone else who rebuilt
all the things that if you're built many
many years ago
but looking at the problems that they
have to face once they're big
because they never thought they're going
to get so big it's a guy who wanted to
[ __ ] fix a sword
and now he has okay 200 billion i don't
know huge [ __ ] company
okay so i can see the the bitcoin
maximalists
they're coming from the angle there's
going to be ethereum and then something
else is going to take over that and
something else is going to take over
that and it's going to keep evolving and
so it's not reliable
uh and people should just put their
money in bitcoin because it's just going
to slowly grow
with some ups and downs yes absolutely
it's probably better risk to reward
if you want to invest bitcoin is
probably the best
like anybody who tells you otherwise is
probably lying because they want to sell
you something
but that's not true right you had
myspace and then you had facebook
and then facebook's only objective
nowadays is to make sure that nobody can
kill them
so they buy instagram and then they buy
this and then they buy that
the only objective the only purpose they
have is to make sure that they stay
alive
so that that is not really true because
any organization can get that big
to stay alive okay
cool well if people want to learn more
about
dow maker or find you what social media
handles should they follow
sure they can join us on twitter or big
on twitter it's the dow maker it's like
the facebook
we didn't remove them and we're also
quite big on tick tock
for the younger generation i think on
tiktok it's just dow maker
so we killed it yeah i think those are
the two main platforms
okay fantastic that was very interesting
thank you
i understood most of what you're saying
we'll see what the audience thinks but
yeah
that was fascinating thank you very much
for coming on thank you so much for
having me
and it was a pleasure
you